well for years I said my favorite Pixar
movie is up but now that has finally
changed to inside out not only the best
Pixar film ever written but one of the
best Disney films I've ever seen this is
a movie that takes an idea and does
everything great that you can do with it
the setup is that everybody's mind is
fuelled by emotions and here the
emotions are personalized they're
basically what you would think joy is
very happy sandesh is very depressed
fear is very paranoid you get the idea
we focus on the emotions of a girl named
Riley who's moving from one new location
to another such a large change is
throwing her emotions out of whack and
we find that joy and sin as are
accidently separated from headquarters
and dropped off somewhere else
thus the movie is just them trying to
get back in order to bring balance back
to Riley's emotional state in doing so
joy and sadness to polar opposites have
to find a way to get along in order to
work together now the idea of emotions
having personalities in your head is
nothing new this has been done in Warner
Brothers cartoons Disney cartoon and
hell there's even a sitcom about called
Herman's head but this is the first one
that said maybe we can not only do
something funny with this but also
really dramatic something that anybody
of any age can understand the story is
actually a coming-of-age story talking
about change talking about adapting
talking about sacrifices talking about
how some things have to be pushed out of
your mind and replaced with others and
all the hardships of growing up are
shown through these characters who are
developing Riley as she goes through
these tough moments whether you're a kid
going through these moments or an adult
who used to go through these moments
everybody can sympathize you get these
problems you get these frustrations you
understand how hard it is to adapt but
at the same time it balances out with a
lot of bright colors and funny moments
and goofy moments which is really what
the film is about balance joy and
sadness don't get along but like a lot
of buddy movies they realize that they
have to get along well here it actually
serves a purpose joy is the one who's
usually in charge and tries to keep
sadness off to the sidelines but the
movie so brilliantly shows how much joy
and sandjas are actually tied together I
won't give away but let's just say it's
brilliant
summed up through visuals that everybody
can understand and everybody can relate
to so many of us try to run away from
sand as we think it's not healthy but
this movie shows it's unbelievably
healthy all your emotions are healthy
you just had to know how to keep them in
check the movie shows it's okay to feel
however you feel there's no shame in
feeling sad there's no shame in feeling
angry if anything by confronting them
you create new emotions and new moments
and the best thing is it sticks to the
choices they make when they move they
stay moved when a character has to
disappear he stays disappeared they
don't pull any happily-ever-after
reckoning stuff no they mean this stuff
for serious because it's all part of
growing up and you're gonna have to go
through hardships and you're just gonna
have to accept it it's so great that a
movie about emotions talks about all
this in fact it's the perfect movie to
talk about all this with all the
unnecessary Pixar sequels coming out
this is one of the few that I would love
to see a sequel to I would love to see
movies that follows Riley into adulthood
the same way the toys and Toy Story grow
up with Andy I would love to see the
emotions grow up with Riley what new
developments could we relate to and in
what creative way would they show it
there's so many opportunities with this
idea in fact if you watch the blu-ray
you can see all the other ideas they
were gonna do but couldn't because there
wasn't enough time they're all great and
I love to see more of these come about
this is a movie that not only leaves me
wanting more it leaves me wanting a lot
more why can't this get a spinoff
universe why can't this have other
stories and other characters that can
lead to other movies to me that's the
sign of a really really good flick I
guess if I really have to nitpick the
only problem I have is that it could
have been a little funnier like there's
a scene where they had to wake up this
scary clown in order to give her a
nightmare that thing could have been a
lot scarier and led to a lot more comedy
there's a few lines and a few scenes I
thought could have used just a little
bit more of a punch to it well I
definitely laughed out a lot of scenes I
wasn't laughing super hard at least not
as much as some of the other Pixar films
but like I said it's a nitpick really
everything from the most part balances
out incredibly well I still laughed at
the right moments I still cried at the
right moments quite fittingly every
emotion that's supposed to play
plays out every time I see it it gets
better and better the stories the
characters the layout it's just
phenomenal in my opinion it's as perfect
a Pixar movie as you can get and
definitely a good one to end this Disney
cember on thank you all once again for
watching I hope you enjoyed and yeah
maybe in January I'll do a few by
popular demands again but for this year
it's great to see that Disney is still
dishing out the creativity and new ideas
and continuing to inspire thank you all
so much for joining me and I'll see you
next year